stellt euch vor ihr seid krank und euer
schmerzmittel oder antidepressiva oder
sogar euer krebsmittel ist über wochen
oder sogar monate einfach ausverkauft
das ganze ist kein abstraktes problem
mehr sondern alltag in ganz vielen
apotheken und das nicht irgendwo auf der
welt sondern hier in deutschland
habt ihr das vielleicht selber sogar
schon mal erlebt hier oben könnt ihr
eine kleine umfrage teilnehmen oder ihr
schreibt uns einfach in die kommentare
es wird uns auf jeden fall interessieren
wir wollen in dieser folge somit auf
jeden fall mal darauf gucken wie groß
das problem überhaupt ist was die
ursachen dafür sind und ob und wenn ja
wie die ausweitung des corona virus dazu
führen könnte dass es sogar noch
schlimmer wird
[Musik]
wir wollten heute eigentlich ein ganz
normales erklär video machte uns zu den
medikamenten engpässen in deutschland
und darum das ist immer mehr medikamente
gibt irgendwie nicht lief aber sind das
hat unterschiedliche gründe
aber das war auch heute morgen noch ganz
weit weg und da ist das hier passiert ja
wie ist die lage
mein kollege chris macht gerade nämlich
genau die erfahrung über die sich ihr
heute sprechen wollen
und deswegen ist das problem irgendwie
gar nicht mehr so weit weg und nur für
den erklärt filmen wollen hier im büro
und deswegen rufen einfach mal an und
fragen was da los war und was sie da und
habe mitgeteilt das ist eine antibiotika
gerade wegen dessen verfügbar ist und
deswegen setze auf ein anderes
antibiotikum gestellt und weil das wird
ein ganz normales alltags prozedere oder
irgendwie gesagt ja es tut uns so bleibt
das verändert jetzt irgendwas eine
medikation oder ist das einfach nur ja
bis jetzt halt ein anderes produkt wie
bei chris schafften es die apotheken im
krankenhaus oder in der stadt in den
meisten fällen ein ersatz zu finden aber
das klappt nicht immer und das problem
wächst immer häufiger fehlen medikamente
oder sogar die wirkstoffe und da fast
alles in asien hergestellt wird könnte
das problem durch das corona virus sogar
noch schlimmer werden
aktuell sind in deutschland offizielle
liste circa 270 arzneimittel nicht
lieferbar insgesamt zugelassen sind in
deutschland aber 103.000 medikamente für
menschen dh es ist weniger als ein
prozent aber je nachdem wie sie ein
mensch darauf angewiesen ist reicht
genau dieses eine medikament oder dieses
eine prozent das fehlt und es geht dabei
nicht nur um bestimmte mittel sondern um
ganz unterschiedliche das hängt mit der
normalen ibuprofen an geht über
antidepressiva blutdruckmittel bis hin
zu krebsmedikamenten und wenn dann ein
medikament fehlt müssen die therapien
unterbrochen verschoben oder sogar
komplett umgestellt werden nur weil das
medikament gerade nicht verfügbar ist
laut apothekenverband haben sich die
lieferengpässe jedes jahr seit 2000 17
verdoppelt 2009 10 waren 18 millionen
packungen rabattarzneimittel nicht
lieferbar ein licht vereinbart ist
natürlich nicht gleich einen
versorgungsnotstand das heißt in den
meisten fällen kann man ausweichen aber
das geht eben nicht immer und all das
hat bisher rein gar nichts mit dem
corona virus zu tun und es ist auch
nichts neues
warnung von experten gibt es schon seit
über zehn jahren dass die ausfälle seit
jahren zunehmen hat unterschiedliche
gründe aber einer der hauptgründe ist
dass in europa fast keine wirkstoffe
mehr produziert werden
80 der wirkstoffe kommen aus
billiglohnländern in asien die meisten
aus china und indien
und da vor ort dann meistens auch noch
aus wenigen fabriken dh wenn einer der
produzenten ausfällt weil irgendwas
verunreinigt war oder die produktion ins
stocken gerät hat das auswirkungen auf
die ganze welt das macht die medikamente
bei uns zum einen besonders günstig zum
anderen macht es uns aber auch besonders
abhängig sehr sarkastisch formuliert
sage ich gerne die chinesen brauchen gar
keine atombombe
sie liefern einfach keine antibiotika
und dann erledigt sich europa man muss
ein bisschen war eine atombombe geht
schneller
aber dann erledigt sich europa von
allein das klingt extrem aber
tatsächlich gibt es in deutschland kein
hersteller für antibiotika mehr der
letzte hat 2017 dichtgemacht die
unternehmen sagen für sie lohnt es sich
kaum in europa zu produzieren weil der
kostendruck so hoch sein wie sind wir
jetzt in diese abhängigkeit geraten ja
das ist die frage
nach henne und ei nicht was ist denn
zuerst da gewesen der kostendruck und
dann ist man nach china und indien
gegangen um preiswerte oder man kann sie
auch einfach seien billiger produzieren
zu können
aber es ist natürlich auch so die
pharmafirmen wollen natürlich auch ihren
gewinn optimieren und das läuft
miteinander parallel als ein grund für
den kostendruck bei den unternehmen den
experten immer wieder das sogenannte
rabattsystem das heißt dass
krankenkassen rabattverträge mit
bestimmten herstellern abschließen
und sie sagen damit wir nehmen euch
dieses medikament ab und sorgen dafür
dass unsere versicherten dieses
medikament verschrieben bekommen das
macht es zwar für die krankenkassen und
für die patienten billiger erhöht aber
den druck auf die pharmakonzerne die
planken für sie zudem deutschland
entscheiden aufgrund eines einzigen
kriteriums das ist der preis das heißt
die krankenversicherung entscheidet sich
nicht für den anbieter mit dem besten
preis leistungsverhältnis sondern sie
nehmen nur die emi im billigsten
anbieter das bedeutet auch dass dann die
hersteller die keinen rabattvertrag
abschließen ihre produktion entweder
drosseln oder sogar ganz einstellen wenn
dann der hauptproduzent mit dem
rabattvertrag ein liefer problem hat
bricht die ganze kette zusammen denn so
schnell können andere unternehmen ihre
produktion nicht wieder nach oben fahren
das bringt uns zu der frage welche
auswirkungen hat jetzt das corona virus
auf die versorgung und diese frage lässt
sich ganz ohne weiteres seriös
beantworten denn die situation ändert
sich sowohl in den produzierenden
ländern als auch hier vor ort täglich
oder sogar stündlich
aktuell kommen in indien sogar schon
weniger wirkstoffe aus china an
und das land hat deswegen ankündigt den
export von einigen mitteln
einzuschränken
das heißt es kann also sein dass es
durchaus zu weiteren engpässen kommt
trotzdem besteht wohl kein grund zur
panik die zuständige behörde betont dass
es aktuell keine konkreten hinweise
darauf gibt dass die engpässe sich durch
corona verschärfen und das gilt wohl
mindestens bis im herbst auch die
meisten hersteller betonen sie seien gut
was trotzdem auch klar ist wenn die
produktion in indien oder in china
gedrosselt wird und sei es nur weil die
angestellten krank sind und der
weltweite güterverkehr eingeschränkt
wird entweder von den staaten oder auch
da einfacher die menschen krank sind
dann könnte das fatale folgen haben wenn
dort jetzt aufgrund des coda virus die
lieferwege gestört sind kann es sein
dass in drei bis sechs monaten die
ersten patienten patienten keine
antibiotika bekommen mit
dementsprechenden konsequenzen muss im
schlimmsten fall todes werden fühlen
kann
die politik ist spätestens jetzt
alarmiert und fordert mehr medikamente
made in europe
aber sie kann den unternehmen natürlich
nicht vorschreiben wo sie ihre
wirkstoffe einkaufen und wo sie zu
produzieren haben und eine
rückverlagerung wird ohne finanzielle
anreize oder bestimmte sicherheiten für
die unternehmen höchstwahrscheinlich
nicht funktionieren auch die
pharmakonzerne und die apotheker haben
natürlich diverse forderungen was ich am
system ändern sollte beide fordern
allerdings eine veränderung des
rabattsystems sie wollen gesetzlich
verpflichtend bewirken dass mehr als ein
hersteller bei den rabattverträgen von
den krankenversicherungen zum zug kommt
bisher schien sich fahrer konzerne
politik krankenkassen und apotheken
gerne gegenseitig die schuld zu für eine
wirkliche veränderung brauchen wir viel
zeit und geld und das problem war vor
kroner schon groß und könnte jetzt
vermutlich noch größer werden wenn ihr
auf bestimmte medikamente angewiesen
sein fragt am besten mal bei eurem arzt
nach
[Musik]
hier findet ihr noch ein video mit mehr
informationen zum corona virus und hier
unten unsere playlist und nicht
vergessen abonnieren